if you read a text or hear something new
your mind has a strong desire for order
and consistency
the moment your brain holds two
contradicting ideas you experience
distress
your mind often resolves this problem by
tweaking the ideas until they become
consistent with the other stories you
tell yourself to be true
meat eaters for example who are
confronted with new information of how
their dinner came about can either eat
less meat deploy strategies to cope with
the new information such as denial or do
a little bit of both
foreign
ideas are deeply ingrained in our
identity the mental imbalance can become
overwhelming and intoxicate our thoughts
and as a result we may believe even the
most absurd conspiracy theories to keep
our sanity it helps to learn about this
phenomenon known as cognitive dissonance
[Music]
after a severe earthquake in India
rumors circulated among people who felt
the shock but sustained no damage about
an even worse disaster That was supposed
to strike
however no disaster followed and
psychologists began to wonder why such
rumors sprang into existence it seemed
counter-intuitive that people would
share and believe fear-provoking stories
during such a difficult time
nearly 20 years passed before Leon
festinger a young psychologist had a
plausible Theory the rumors were not
fear provoking but instead fear
justifying
the argument if we feel afraid and safe
at the same time we invent explanations
to reduce such conflicting states of
Mind fasting a call this mental
imbalance cognitive dissonance
[Music]
cognitive dissonance is based on the
idea that when two ideas are
psychologically not consistent with each
other we change them and make them
consistent
vesting is then examined whether a
cognitive dissonance can be strong
enough to believe in conspiracy theories
even after they are proven wrong
to do so two colleagues and festinger
joined a small apocalyptic cult led by
Dorothy Martin a Suburban housewife
Martin claimed to receive messages from
Superior beings from another planet
called Clarion the messages purportedly
said that a flood would destroy the
world on December 21st 1954.
the psychologists observed that many
members quit their jobs and let go of
their possessions in preparation for the
end of the world
when the day came and passed peacefully
Martin claimed that the world had been
spared because of the force of good that
the members had spread
to cope with the situation and the heavy
cognitive dissonance It produced the
psychologists hypothesized that the
members had two options
they could either change their
situations and let go of their beliefs
and actions that formed the identity of
their former self
or they could Embrace new beliefs to
stay in the cult and protect the image
they had formed of themselves
and that's exactly what happened
some members face the facts and left the
cult to regain their sanity While others
believed Martin's story to keep their
threatened worldview alive
in their assessment the psychologists
concluded that three conditions made it
especially hard for members to quit
[Music]
1. if the members had deep convictions
that were relevant to their everyday
routines 2. if they had done things that
were difficult to undo 3. if they
received social support from other
believers
Leon festinger later wrote a man with a
conviction is a hard man to change tell
him you disagree and he turns away show
him facts and he questioned your sources
appeal to logic and he fails to see your
point
what are your thoughts do you have an
idea how we can change our and other
people's minds if reason falls on deaf
ears can experience maybe do the trick
share your thoughts and experience with
cognitive dissonance in the comments
below
foreign
[Music]
this and all other Sprouts videos are
licensed under Creative Commons that
means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms online
courses or to start projects and today
thousands already do to learn how it
works and download this video without
ads or background music check out our
website or read the description below
if you want to support our mission and
help change education visit our patreon
that's patreon.com sprouts